[Music]
you know one of our fundamental premises
with human plus machine is really the
plus part of human plus machine there's
been a lot of this dialogue about
polarizing extremes of the machines can
do certain things and humans can do
certain things and as a result we end up
with this you know this this battle kind
of pitting what the machines will do
versus the humans we think that creates
the wrong dynamics so if humans you know
human plus machine we're trying to
reframe the dialogue - where's what's
the real interesting space and really
the big space where humans and machines
collaborate and we call collaborative
intelligence and come together and help
people you know provide people with
better tools powered by AI to do what
they do more effectively and if you
think about it that way it we really
believe that with AI we're not moving
into a more machine oriented age we're
actually moving into an age it's more
human age where we can accentuate what
makes us human empowered by more
powerful tools that are they're more
human-like in their ability and that
creates these new types of jobs so we
call that the missing middle because
there hasn't been a lot of discussion
about these jobs in the middle where
people and machines collaborate and
we've come up with two sets of jobs and
one on one side you have the jobs where
people are needed to help machines and
that's not a category that too many
people focus on we think it's an
important one I'll come back to that in
a minute on the other side we have a set
of jobs where machines help people
machines give people new superpowers and
those are the two broad categories of
jobs we see in the missing middle you
know so that set of jobs where where
people are needed to help machines
there's a few interesting novel new
categories of jobs we found that people
don't often think about and we call
those trainers explainers and sustainers
and they're very important you know very
important things for all organizations
to think about as you think about how to
deploy artificial intelligence in your
organization so think about a trainer
what we mean by trainer is it's a new
type of job where a person is needed to
train AI or you know train the machines
that we're using in businesses and we're
not talking about simple things like you
know tagging data for supervised
learning that's included but that's just
the start of it what we're really
talking about here is more sophisticated
forms of training that are needed to so
that our
artificial intelligence in our systems
behave properly for example for a you
know companies we're working with their
developing chat BOTS in virtual agents
if you're a bank you might want a very
different type of personality than a
media company or a gaming company or a
casino and embodying the personality the
behavior the culture the characteristics
the nature of the response in your your
AI is a really important consideration
for companies because we talked about
the idea that with AI you know AI
becomes the brand of your company
because it's the face of the company how
your company is perceived by your
customers this idea of a trainer that
brings in skills to develop that kind of
behavioral response for your AI is a
really important skill and we're hiring
people to do these jobs today you know
people with backgrounds and things like
sociology psychology in other areas not
a technical skill but a new type of role
that's very important to get AI right as
you apply to your organization
another type of job where we see people
needed to help machines our explainers
and sustainers and I'll talk about these
two a little bit together explainers our
new roles where we need people in roles
that think where they can explain the
implications of artificial intelligence
one thing you hear a lot about is
blackbox ai ai can't be explained we
don't know how its operating and yes
that's true for certain forms of AI we
need explainers to help us decide when
can you when is it appropriate to use
blackbox
AI and those types of algorithms and
when do you need to be able to explain
how you arrived at a decision and in
every organization you're gonna have
cases where you need to explain in cases
where you know it's okay to use more of
a blackbox algorithm we need explainers
to help organisations make those
decisions and then also explainers to
step in once the decisions being been
made to explain the business
consequences of it you know after the
fact so it explainer becomes a very
important capability and then sustainer
is also important sustainers are looking
at what are the ongoing implications of
using AI is the AI performing as
expected what are some of the rules
around how you're in policies around how
to use a on your company and with some
of the things that are the headlines
today that we see you know in in in
recent weeks things like what's
happening what happened the tragic
circumstance with uber with with a
being killed tragically in Arizona or
Facebook in the headlines over what
turns out to be legal you know use of
their information under their policy but
a policy that's being questioned these
are areas where companies need
explainers and sustainers to think about
not the implementation of the technology
but the appropriate use of the
technology the transparency made the
ability to explain it and that's what
we're talking about with the explainer
and sustainer rolls and this isn't
something just for tech companies every
company is developing digital platforms
they're using data in novel ways they're
developing increasingly intrinsic
consumer services customer services and
experiences using artificial
intelligence and other technologies so
every organization needs to embrace and
understand these new roles these new
issues involved in applying AI to their
organizations now the other side of the
missing middle is where machines help
people and give people your superpowers
as we talked about and there's three
categories of jobs we identified here as
well based on our research there's jobs
where where machines or AI amplifies
people so we call it amplify those jobs
were machines aid and interaction so
that interact category and then there's
embody which is actual physical
interaction robotics and cobots and such
and those are the jobs where machines
and AI really empower people and allow
them to do more steve an example that we
see here that's that's interesting is
you think about the amplifi category you
know one great example is autodesk you
know which is designed software autocad
that designers use to do software it
used to be it was very much like
engineering drawings and where you had
an engineer or designer specifying
exactly what they needed well with with
the dream catcher with the degenerative
design software using AI you know that
auto that Autodesk dealers with AutoCAD
designers can now use AI to multiply the
power of their creativity AI can amplify
their own creativity come up with
thousands of designs based on
constraints and parameters that the
designer sets and then the designers own
creative skills come into play to to
curate and select and modify those
designs to produce a truly unique human
and creative output and that's an
example of you know software and AI
amplifying the capabilities of an
individual and one of these a great
example of this you know giving a
designer in this case the power to do
more and do more creatively leveraging
their human skills you know a great
example of interacting to the
interaction skills where machines can
help people is what we see in customer
service we're seeing a widespread use of
virtual agents and chat BOTS and AI
technologies like that to help automate
and better serve customer needs in many
many industries but a real interesting
use case we're seeing in many industries
is how a I and these chat box can help
people serve customers more effectively
how we can use virtual agents to
automate the mundane tasks so a customer
service worker doesn't meet you spend
time typing on a keyboard but can spend
time empathizing and communicating with
a customer one example that we've seen
is in a banking environment where
there's a lot of compliance rules and an
agent may always be thinking about what
are the compliance restrictions
regulations and looking at their
computer and deciding how to do all the
compliance as they're interacting with a
customer well that's a case where
companies are applying virtual agents
that are kind of a wingman for the
customer service agent listening for the
conversation watching the transactions
understanding the compliance
implications and helping the agent focus
their time in the consumer and
offloading the compliance driven
obligations it's a great example again
of the Machine partnering with the human
to allow the human to do what they do
best empathizing and interacting with
the customer well the AI takes on
compliance and other transactional
activities and finally embodies where
you see people working together with
physical robotics robotics so it's
embodying you know physical capability
of people along with robotics what an
example that we talked about in the book
that I think is a powerful illustration
of this is Mercedes with their new
s-class Factory you know with the
s-class vehicles Mercedes used to be
heavily automated over 80 percent
automated using large scale and just
realized robots for the factory what
they found was that that was too
inflexible it didn't allow them to be
adaptive and flexible and personalized
enough to meet the demand of their
customers so Mercedes got a reverse
engineer the factory implemented brought
more people into the process equipped
the people with cobots that people can
dynamically adapt and added more people
to the equation with cobots
so that they got more personal
nation better productivity in the
factory than they did in the heavily
automated sense so that's a great
example of using advanced technology
artificial intelligence robotics
combined with people to produce an
outcome that was much better for the
business in this case the manufacturing
process one of the fusion skills that's
really interesting is judgment
integration and judgment integration is
talking about how do we combine the
judgment of a person with a judgment of
a machine and combine it together to
make the best decision between the two
of them an illustration why this is
important is it comes from a recent
Harvard Medical Survey were study that
they did they looked at to the the
accuracy of a breast cancer breast tumor
detection it turns out algorithms are
about you know AI right now can detect
breast breast tumor conditions with
about 92% accuracy physicians can do
that at about 96 percent accuracy if you
put the two together and give a
physician access to the results from the
from the algorithm it's 99.5% accurate
so it's the combination of the human
plus the Machine gives you the best
outcome and we find this in profession
across profession
[Music]
you